Today's the day
It's really sad to say that I've actually never voted before
And i never really felt that there was
UGHH
Unfortunately the stereotypical thing is
My vote doesn't really count
When technically yeah it really freaking does
Especially in an election like this where
IT ME VERY  UPSET
Im packing my voting bag
I need to have some snacks incase the lines really long
I'm mostly upset because
I feel like this election has turned into just
one huge joke
it is just one candidate bullying
the other, the other bullying the other
thats like the opposite
of what we want in this country
its just more hate filled
anything.. like everything
i just feel like its all just completely hate filled
people are more excited about this election to be over
then about having a possibility
of a new president
and hopefully they'll bring
changes to this country that can actually
help those who need it
I'm sorry I can't bring you to vote
I love you
I know, hmmm
Yeah, we'll just leave those kisses.. for your own mouth
The last thing that I want is for my comments to turn hate-filled
You have a right to vote for whoever you want and that is the best part about this country
So if you strongly believe.. one candidate is better than the other,
then unfortunately, that's your view and that's something that has to be respected
So please I challenge you to be kind in the comments on this day of need.
Judging by the title you guys are probably wondering, who am i gonna vote for.
I think it's pretty clear who I'm gonna vote for.
So here's the thing,
(sighs)
If we're judging purely on somebody who actually has a background in politics
and knows what goes into being a president
Who has been in the white house herself
long enough
to understand everything that goes into it
I think she's way more capable than Trump
who I don't think will even bring himself to live in the white house
I'm sure it wouldn't be good enough or up to his standards
Maybe I'm wrong but
I would love to see if Trump is president
how often and how much time he actually spends
in the white house
uhhh goodness.
Alright well I guess I should probably go vote now
I'm stressed out I feel
I feel physically ill right now
uphhh
Come'on! Go to your cage!
Good boy!
Mommy's got to go vote okay
I'll be right back honey
You stay here and be a good boy
Like I'm feeling physically ill because I
I just
Oh God!
I'm scared! I'm scared for me, I'm scared for you, I'm scared for all of us!
Canada I hope you will welcome me with open arms
I've never really been there
but I hear great things
Everyone I've ever really met from Canada is really nice
Oh God!
Can't forget my dongle!
I have a feeling that the line is gonna be really long
So the good news is that I will listen to an audiobook
Oh goodness I have to go to Starbucks so I can ease my nerves!
One of the things I'm even more concerned about is the outcome of no matter who wins
The divide in this country is going to be so great
and I don't want people to be mad or upset
Everyone's so angry I wish people can just be happy
Oh God!
Ahhhhhhhh
I need a coffee!
and a breakfast sandwich!
and a new president!
I'm about to start my period so I think that means that Hillary is gonna win
I think Hillary is going to be president
Because today my app says that today is the day
Hillary... this one's for you girl
This ones for you and can we lower tampon taxes because it's not a luxury item it's a need
Thanks!
Got the sandwich
Now it's time to go vote
Oh God I'm so anxious
Ohhhhh
I feel sick
Voting should be an exciting thing
It should be an exciting time
I was studying up last night on all of the other propositions that there are to vote on
There's so much more to vote for than just the president
and
all of these other things
no matter who the president is
the smaller propositions also mean so much
to your community
to your state.
so study up.
These are my feet walking
This is my drink I'm drinking
I just have like so many things to say and so many thoughts and
It is also it's even so sad that the fact that
you know Trump is so crazy but
his promise to make America great again is something that is powering people to go vote for him
because they are so incredibly unhappy with how things are
in the world that we live in
Why can't it be someone else? Why can't it be anyone else?
I don't understand. He's a personality not a president
He's treating this whole thing like a reality show like it's
It's not a reality show this is actually real life
and for someone who has spent their entire life
creating fake fictitious worlds
That's not... That's not what we want!
It's not what we want but if thats what you want to vote for
I you know you're entitled to your own opinion
Oh God!
Okay voted
Here's the thing I learned from voting for the first time
and thankfully last night Jenna and I were doing some research on
things that you're supposed to be voting for
and the different acts and things like that
I can guarantee that most of the people voting
don't even know what the heck they are voting for
which makes me extremely concerned
for the fact that people are just checking boxes
for things that they don't even know so like
yeah your vote counts but like if you don't know what you're actually voting for
I don't think you should even vote at all
Which is one of the reasons why I wanted to vote this year
because you can't complain about something if you didn't actually have a voice in making the decision
So I felt that it was only fair that if I wanted to complain about who actually wins this election
I need to have at least tried my best to do my part
and say "Hey this is what I want" and I'm gonna hope for the best
*laughs*
Hee Hee do you know that you have a sticker on your head?
Do you know that you got sticker on your head?
Honey, you hate me don't you?
I did my voting deed
Again I said this so many times
No matter who it is that you voted for, be kind to each other
because that is really the only hope that we have left
Even though this election is over no matter who is elected we still will have another four years with them
So we have to attempt to make the best of whatever situation that we're thrown into
So
friends
Happy election day
I'm gonna edit this video and I'm gonna play Call of Duty to forget everything
I'll see you guys later bye